le bras de fer reprend entre madrid et
barcelone ce mercredi le premier
ministre espagnol pedro sanchez ainsi
que le président catalan père aragonès
se sont réunis afin de discuter de
l'avenir du processus indépendantiste en
catalogne cela faisait 18 mois qu'ils ne
s'étaient pas réunis pour aborder
clairement le sujet mais avec la rentrée
politique est bien la sphère revient sur
la table l'objectif de cette réunion est
bien c'était d'essayer de trouver ou de
commencer à trouver une sortie de crise
à ce problème alors d'un côté on a le
président catalan qui lui demandent un
référendum d'autodétermination pour sa
région et de l'autre on a le premier
ministre espagnol qui lui proposait bien
simplement un nouveau financement pour
la catalogne alors si chacun semble
faire un pas vers l'autre les
discussions restent très complexe et
notamment parce que le contexte n'aide
pas il faut rappeler que la semaine
dernière et bien il y a eu des
désaccords technique entre madrid et
barcelone qui ont fait que le projet
d'agrandissement de l'aéroport de
barcelone est bien a été suspendu et de
l'autre côté il ya eu également le 11
septembre la fête de la catalogne durant
laquelle la manifestation
indépendantiste a réuni bien plus de
monde que prévu ce qui donne
l'impression que le mouvement est bien
reprend des forces je vous propose
d'ailleurs d'écouter elisenda pas
louzier l'une des organisatrice de cette
manifestation une voix y possède donc
négocier
pour aboutir à l'indépendance quoi c'est
toujours mieux qu'une voie unilatérale
mais le prendre espagnol et pas le
gouvernement britannique est honnie la
possibilité même de l'autodétermination
de la catalogne donc une négociation qui
se base pas sur le respect de l'autre
termine à sion nous on n'est pas
d'accord
une négociation doit être basée sur la
reconnaissance de la catalogne comme
nation comme peuple qui a le droit à
décider par lui-même pour résumer même
s'il s'agissait d'une rencontre
importance car la première depuis
plusieurs mois elle ne signe pas non
plus l'issue de ce problème de la crise
catalane pedro sanchez continue à
refuser un référendum mais il insiste
sur les aides financières européennes
que recevra la catalogne et il ne se
ferme pas au dialogue